[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[за підтримки «Лавка традицій».
Продукти від маленьких господарств]
[Старий Порицьк,
Волинь]
Я — Валентин Обштир,
власник органічної ферми «Старий Порицьк».
[Валентин Обштир
Власник підприємства]
Ми знаходимося на одному з наших полів, тут у нас росте жито,
зараз якраз його жнивують.
Жито в нас є однією зі складових
корму для наших корів.
Окрім жита, ще [є] група бобових,
пшениця і ячмінь, овес.
Ми знаходимося в південній частині Волинської області,
у досить історичній місцевості,
де знаходяться два населених пункти:
Порицьк [нині — Павлівка] і Старий Порицьк.
Ці села ще відомі ще з часів Литовської доби на Волині.
У нас тут 960 гектарів в обробітку.
Всі вони під органікою з першого дня,
тобто ми не переводили це якось частинами,
як буває в інших господарствах.
У 2010 році перша посівна в нас
була повністю за органічними технологіями.
Органічне виробництво — це наш
дідівський спосіб вирощування
і виробництва продукції,
тільки плюс механізація [процесу].
Органічне молоко, органічний йогурт
починається ось звідси, з цієї землі.
Ця земля, крім органічних добрив,
нічого не бачила.
Сільським господарством я б ніколи не займався,
за фахом я економіст.
Це моя батьківщина, мій батько тут починав,
і всі ці чинники свою роль зіграли,
що ми опинилися саме тут з цим проєктом.
Тут була старенька ферма, яка почала будуватися
ще в 1970-х роках за мого батька.
Тут було два тваринницьких комплекси,
які ми повністю реконструювали.
Ми тут переробляємо тільки винятково те,
що тут самі й вирощуємо.
Зі сторони тут не заходять ніякі корми,
ніяка інша сировина.
Спочатку з нас тут усі сміялися,
що за органіка,
в області ми — єдине таке велике господарство,
яке займається органікою.
Коли стало видно наші результати,
вже якось трошки по-іншому
почали дивитися [на нас].
На нашій фермі знаходиться порода корів —
українська чорно-ряба голштинізована.
У 2010 році отримали десь поголів'я близько 200 корів.
Тут воно вже було історично,
чорно-рябої худоби.
І от ми її уже років сім голштинізуємо
[збільшуємо продуктивність].
Покращуємо породу, вона все більше й більше стає,
можна сказати, голштином.
У нас на сьогодні близько 350 [голів],
а доїться з них приблизно 300.
Дояться як вдома,
як і годуються, так і дояться.
Основний напрямок — це молочний, на даному етапі
максимально намагаємося його розвивати.
Починали ми просто з сиру плюс кисломолочний сир.
Спочатку це було тільки декілька видів молока і кефіру,
потім — сметана, масло, йогурти тощо...
На цьому столі зараз ми бачимо всі інгредієнти,
з яких готується цей знаменитий
«Старопорицький йогурт».
У першу чергу, це цільна заморожена ягода,
вона проходить дефростацію
[процес розморожування],
і вже з неї готується ось такий наповнювач.
Буквально з мінімальним додаванням органічного цукру,
який виробляться теж у нас в Україні.
Нарешті, сердце нашого сирного бізнесу — це наш підвал.
Власне, тут відбувається дозрівання наших сирів.
У даному випадку тут дозріває три сорти сиру:
«Голландський», «Чеддер» і «Старопорицький» —
наш фірмовий.
Задумуючи нові продукти або якісь нові проєкти
в переробці, я думаю як споживач,
я завжди мислю як споживач.
Тому що в мене велика сім'я, і питання її харчування
я не віддаю нікому на аутсорсинг [підрядництво].
Наш девіз: «Для людей — як для себе».
Треба повертатися до невеликих виробництв.
Вони більш мобільні в потребах
населення в асортименті,
воно ж постійно міняється, а вони більш мобільні в цьому плані.
Це, як би, правильне майбутнє,
а яке буде майбутнє, то ми побачимо.
Ми ж не завжди розвиваємося в правильному напрямку.
Тому, як на мене, то так би мало бути.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Продюсерка
Каріна Пілюгіна]
[Режисерка
Марія Теребус]
[Режисерка монтажу
Надія Мельниченко]
[Оператори
Олег Сологуб, Назар Назарук, Олексій Шандра]
[Звукорежисерка
Анастасія Климова]
[Субтитрувальник
Андрій Довган]
[Коректорка субтитрів
Леся Любченко]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]